all right let's bring you up to speed
with where we're at with the vote
counting right now according to anadolo
state news agency this is the official
state news agency this is not the final
official results though according to
their projections of how vote counting
is going
is still ahead with 52.43 of the vote
is behind him with
47.57 of the vote this projection is
based on 94 of ballot boxes having been
open so still some ballot boxes to be
opened still some counting to be done
but the majority of ballot boxes have
been opened at this point this is the
picture that's emerging let's uh take
the conversation now to set Cedar
damerel she joins us once again thanks
for coming back your professor of
political sciences I've been explaining
to everyone at Ishq University in
Istanbul good to have you with us so
first of all let's start with these
latest projections
is this getting
to
too difficult to see a killer star or
Lou win at this point if 94 of the
ballot boxes have been opened and if
anadolo the official state news agency
is saying there's about five points he's
about Five Points behind erdogan
yes he's about Five Points behind about
two million votes behind pretty much the
same pattern we saw in the first round
it's not a gap that cannot be closed but
it looks like
Ardon is keeping his leading position
so we may see some surprises but
otherwise if you don't get surprised it
looks like Adam is going to keep his
leading position in the end of the
second round to have a surprise as you
put it Cedar tell us what does that mean
does that mean he needs to win virtually
every every vote in every remaining
Ballot Box that hasn't been opened yet
what's that about six percent of ballot
boxes that haven't been over I just want
to get a sense of how Mammoth a surprise
he needs right now A change in general
for instance right over the past 30
minutes we saw
increasing his votes in Istanbul so he's
ahead right now in Istanbul he wasn't
half an hour ago and in Ankara he is
closing the Gap is increasing his voice
as well so in crowded cities like
Istanbul and Ankara or maybe crowded
cities in the Southeast like the
arbucker his votes may increase
um more than expected over the next
couple hours that could
lead to a change in the election results
but otherwise so he needs to win the big
cities to win the big cities and there
is a change we observe in the big cities
while we don't see much of a change in
the other cities so the change if
there's going to be a change it will
come from the big cities it looks like
but that looks like a hard ask right it
looks like
is a much more comfortable position
right now
that is right that is right right all
right let's you talk to us a little bit
about how it's shaping up in the cities
let's talk a little bit about how it's
shaping up nationally any surprises in
other areas so far from the distribution
of votes as we've seen them
well we saw that the turnout is a little
bit lower than the first round but not
dramatically lower but in the Southeast
we saw a more observable decline in the
turnout it looks like Kurds were not
enthusiastic about the rising National
Stone of the cholesterol campaign in the
second round that's something we could
say so far all right said always good
talking to you thanks so much for
sharing your perspective on this so here
we have it there's uh well it's gone up
to 95 of ballot boxes having been open
so they're getting on with it still a
lead by about five points for Egypt type
erdogan let's go over to rasool sardari
joins us live from the presidential
Palace in Ankara how are they reacting
to this
well there is a kind of uh celebration
mode here we have seen just a little ago
there was a quite loud music that just
started here and there are the
preparations on the way uh for erdogan's
balcony speech so traditionally he will
deliver that speech uh on the balcony of
the awkward is headquarter in Ankara but
this time he has decided to address his
supporters and also the nation in case
if he wins from the presidential uh
palace here so Sami according to the the
presidential sources according to their
own system so far around 95 percent of
the awards have been counted and present
to erdog one according to them is
leading by
52.4 percent of the of the war so that's
why now they're almost sure that erdogan
is going to finish this election by
being re-elected and then saying that
after four decades in politics and 20 of
the two decades being in power the
leader of the company as prime minister
and then as the president he is once
again showing that so almost impossible
to to to defeat him in the ballot boxes
despite all of the odds one of the
highest inflation rates in the world
skyrocketing prices and also one of the
biggest disaster natural disasters that
just happened over uh four months ago
that killed more than 50 000 people in
turkey at the twin earthquakes despite
all of that odds it seems that erdogan
held his ground and opposition failed to
convince people that they will be able
to do better than erdogan
is there something for us to talk about
here in terms of the pivot towards the
Nationalist camp we saw both candidates
try and reach out to nationalists they
made their pitches and here with 95 of
voting boxes having been opened erdogan
is ahead
something to be said about who reached
out to which Camp within the
nationalists
Sammy as of now looking at the
difference so not only the percentage of
the wars but also the difference the the
number of the votes here in the first
round president erdogan finished the
first round by 2.5 million words
difference so now as as of now by 95
percent of the wars being counted we see
that that difference is smaller so it is
2.3 million and in that sense many of
the experts here are saying that it
seems that the Nationalist Awards 60 of
the Nationalist Awards went to
kalistarovo and around 40 percent of the
woods went to uh the president erdogan
but here one of the other uh interesting
thing is that as of now it's not clear
however some of the experts are claiming
on that as if they're saying that the
Kurdish Waters which were the other
swing Wars that the number of the
Kurdish Waters who went to The Ballot
Box was a little bit lesser than the
previous one so in this sense we can see
also a slight decrease in the turnout as
well but at the end of the day we can
say that comfortably we can't say that
almost the Nationalist wars were divided
health and health so during the second
round of the campaign we have seen that
both leaders both president Edwin and
opposition leader Kamal
have have tried very hard to appeal to
these National Wars nationalist Wars
because it was roughly more than 5.2
percent and that was the factor that
forced the election to go to the second
round so being in their support many
people will believe in that they are
going to be the king makers and their
support is going to determine the
outcome here so now we can see that both
have have failed and have succeeded
all right real soon and I'm guessing
they're probably quite happy there in
the presidential Palace and amongst dark
party supporters that their candidate is
ahead so far we have to underscore this
is so far but we're getting towards the
end I think of the ballot box opening
session are they how are they reacting
though to the indication we're getting
that there isn't going to be perhaps a
big chance of a landslide a huge
Landslide victory erdogan
absolutely so uh here we can still say
that this is a neck and neck race
however even the first round of the
election has shown us that it is from
now on is not that much easy for
president erdogan to comfortably win
every election however still the number
is almost around around according to
simulations it's almost around the same
number that he got the same figure that
he received in 2018 during the
presidential election so we can say that
he is holding his ground but on the
other hand as for the first time we have
seen a broad Coalition of the opposition
so six parties came together and choose
the the the chemical as the unity leader
to defeat erdogan so as erdogan is
holding his ground we can see that
slightly the opposition has succeeded to
increase its worth so that is the new
trend so in that sense it seems that
everyone is going to win According to
some simulations by something around 52
percent however that doesn't mean that
there are no challenges for him so the
economy definitely is going to be one of
the main tasks for him and the political
division in the country is also another
another issue and also delivering on
promises as well because there are
hundreds of thousands of people
particularly in the eastern Southeastern
part of turkey those who are affected
who were affected by the earthquakes are
still waiting their houses to be
delivered and so on as I said Forum
number one for that one is not going to
be that much easy to win the elections
however we can comfortably say that
after 40 years in politics and more than
two decades in power as prime minister
and president he's still able to
convince his supporters so that is quite
interesting because he has been the one
who could build emotional connections
between himself and his supporters more
than any other leader in Turkey
all right thanks so much this all
started our reporting to us there from
Ankara from the presidential Palace
let's go to the other side of the Divide
so to speak we can go to Hashem he's
also an anchor but he's with the jehair
pay the opposition party headquarters in
Hashem looking at the numbers looking at
where we're standing right now
96 it's gone up to 96 of ballot boxes
have been counted at this point Hashem
according to the state official anadola
news agency and Thai berdoin is still
about five points ahead of kalistar allu
do they still think they have a chance
to pull this one off what's the mood
there
the remains still cautious Sami saying
that they have to wait even the news
agency which is uh close to the
opposition is saying now that president
erdogan is leading with something like
1.5 million votes at uh
95 percent of the vote count but the
opposition says that they will have to
wait until all the ballots are counted
before they make an announcement they
still believe this is mechanic and they
say we'll have to wait they did
understand from earlier that this is
going to be an extremely
difficult challenge for them basically
how to be able to win the hearts and
minds of at least
2.8 million votes to be able to bridge
the gap between them and president
erdogan particularly following the
results of the first round and then they
saw that the only way for them was to
win the hearts and minds of the ultra
nationalist Vote or hoping for a voter
turnout exceeding 92 percent when you
look all at the indicator you look at
all the indications that we have so far
we're not expecting the voter turnout to
be higher than 86 percent and it's going
to be difficult for them to bridge that
Gap with president but
officially as far as the Turkish
opposition the alliance of six
opposition parties known as the table of
six they say
we still have to wait
and Hashim are they reflecting on the
strategy of cozying up to nationalist
figures like umit ozda and how that
might have impacted their understandings
with the Kurdish voters
well basically Sami so when they looked
at the at the figures they had during
the first round of the election
they were hoping to convince all the
ultra nationalists to join their camp
and move forward offering them what they
say is going to be a better vision for
turkey based on radical reforms of the
economy of the political system
restoring parliamentary system and
putting an end to executive president
presidency the first setback for them
was when Cena andoran said that he's
going to endorse president
then they thought maybe not everybody
who was going to be to fall in line with
sinan and that umid USDA
leader of the victory
party which is an a member of the Atta
Alliance led by Sina noran will vote for
kamales but even that
was not going to be enough for them to
bridge the gap with president
and if you look at the last few days of
the election campaign we saw a totally
different
kamalu embracing more of an
anti-immigration rhetoric saying that as
soon as elected president he will send
all the refugees back home the reason
why he has been focusing on that
particular message hammering all those
all that narrative about the need to
embrace a tough policy when it comes to
immigration because he understood that
his future will rely ultimately on
weather
he will be able to win the hearts and
minds of the ultra nationalists although
his advisors were pretty much skeptical
concerned that getting closer to the
ultra nationalists will ultimately cost
him the sympathy and those of the Kurds
and particularly of the HTTP party and
as you know this was definitely going to
be a delicate task for kamales which is
rallying the support of all the
political factions which are completely
divided about a wide range of issues and
telling them
please just stay together give me your
vote once elected president I'll give
you everything you want now when you
talk to his own people they say it's
still a remarkable Journey for the man
who managed to build together a
coalition of six political parties
come to the first round of the election
get something like 45 percent of the
national vote something which is
unprecedented for the CHP and they still
believe this is a tight race they still
believe that the managed in a way or
another to build Bridges with different
factions of the society now I have to
tell you that when I was talking to many
members of the party Sammy
you could tell
there were really aware about the fact
that this is going to be an extremely
difficult Way Forward for them that is
going to be extremely difficult to
convince people to vote for them
we'll have to wait and see what happens
next as soon as they come out with an
official statement about the final
results that's when we have to wait and
see what would be the next move forward
for the opposition
and as you said it is going to be more
about the future of the opposition and
also the future of
the man who said because of his
background because of his years as a
veteran Member of Parliament as an
economist he have the keys to solve all
the problems of turkey and he said it's
that reputation that will help him
bridge the gap and reach out to the
Turkish people we'll have to wait and
see what he will have to say tonight
we will have to wait and see Hashem but
there's a key Point here as well
I guess you could say on the plus side
for the opposition because well the way
things are looking right now it doesn't
look very
well it looks better for the incumbent
for president I think we can definitely
say that then it does look for command
cholesterol with almost 97 of ballot
boxes open and still a five-point lead
for Roger type erdogan
when you speak with opposition
supporters at this point do you get any
sense of satisfaction in at least the
fact that we're very unlikely to see a
huge Landslide victory for the president
who they've been challenging
Sammy this is no longer the same
momentum the same Vibe the same mood
that we had during the first round of
the election when the opposition was a
hundred percent certain they would be
able to make history and the era of
President erdogan start a new one when I
was talking to people on in May they
were saying something different they
they thought first of all that people in
Turkey will vote with their wallets and
that because of the economy which is in
tatters people would vote for the
opposition that in the earthquake hit
areas people will vote for the
opposition and that the message about
the need to reform the country fix the
economy change the political system is
going to resonate among
millions and millions of Turkish people
and this explains why if you remember in
May the opposition was saying it's a new
chapter it's an historic vote it's the
beginning of a new era they did
understand right after the results of
the first round that a runoff is an
Uncharted Territory not only for
president erdogan because this is the
first time it happens in Turkey but also
for the opposition and the biggest
concern was
to maintain the power base their support
base ask them to come and vote in huge
numbers for Kamal kilistador two they
wanted to convince the ultra
nationalists three they wanted to build
Bridges with the undecided voters four
they were hoping that some of the
supporters
would change their minds and vote for
the opposition and would you look at all
those options it gives you an indication
of the mammoth task facing the
opposition of the uphill climb facing
Camanche list but his supporters
despite the fact that they understand
this is going to be extremely difficult
they remain determined they say we made
the right choice we voted for the man we
think will change the country we voted
for the man we think will restore
democracy we voted for the man who will
build Bridges with the US and the
Europeans
just a while ago the spokesperson of the
party said I will win will usher in a
new spring a spring of democracy in
Turkey so that gives you an idea about
the hopes that they have been harboring
over the last few months and weeks
hoping that tonight would be the moment
when we would tell the Turkish people
history is being made when you look at
the figures the latest updates even from
the news agency close to them you're
getting the indication that the people
of turkey decided to vote
for his rival